now the question is to stream or not to
stream digital technology is
dramatically changing the music business
of course Taylor Swift made headlines
pulling her music from Spotify and added
fuel to the ongoing debate about the
rights of artists Monday night the
American Society of Composers Authors
and publishers better known as ASCAP
held their Centennial awards show right
here in New York City and the money clip
red carpet team yes we have one was
right there we asked artists whether
they support Swiss decision and whether
they find streaming tech a help or a
hindrance do I support you no I think
it's a supposition she's taking the
position and she's adding to the debate
since you're making the debate more
current and more public which is good
you know what whether it helps it or
hurts it doesn't matter it's there
you can't get rid of it you can't go
backwards hopefully we will figure it
out because you can't hide your digital
footprint now we just gotta get the laws
to protect the artists and ways to you
know figure figure this out but you
can't stop technology it's just not
gonna happen we just need to find a new
way you know with the streaming thing is
new so the rules kind of don't apply a
little bit you know what I mean so
they're trying to get the rules changed
so that everybody gets what that is what
they deserve I know you have your MBA
how important is that for musicians
nowadays to have that business
background well with it being more
splintered where the record labels are
doing less and the more independents are
coming up I think it's going to do them
well to be educated in the business
they're in I think it's really important
for us to make the stand no more oh I
didn't know or no more for the art I
didn't get into the education of the
business I think I think you're selling
yourself short
and you're not doing music any favors
and we also asked some of the stars how
they actually obtain their music do they
actually buy it
I'm old-fashioned i buy it i buy a CD i
like to have the CD you know we've kind
of made a stand against streaming and
downloading singles so we're doing all
of our stuff released on ghost tunes and
and and that's it and then buying the
physical CDs we're going old-school I
think we're probably moving to an all
streaming world and we just have to
figure out how to compensate the people
that make the music and and that enrich
people's lives if you could pick only
one way to distribute your songs either
YouTube video put it on iTunes put it on
Spotify what would you pay or even just
making an album if I could choose just
one way yeah sheesh I guess I'd only be
the way that I would do it well you know
as a musician you're always gonna want
it in the highest-quality way but that
can also happen now there's things that
decompress and you can have incredible
quality through the net
I just its consumer is king now you know
I I still happen to love the big vinyl
that had the record with the big cover